[Music]
have you guys heard of this popular
Hmong youtuber based in South Korea
named sue oh no no oh no shower I only
want either kava kava kava and I throw
my computer away
I've got him again I'm gonna get him I'm
gonna get a once every seven you're
disgusting
I don't know what you're talking about
[ __ ] kava avocado drama with that yeah
yeah so [ __ ] yeah I don't know
anyways you know h2 h3 h3 h3 yeah Ethan
Ethan created a video where he was
highlighting all of her like torturous
ways of how she conducts herself in her
ASMR slash mukbang videos so he even
titled it like ASMR has gone way too far
so I'm gonna show you guys a compilation
of some clips of her videos where a lot
of people are saying that this is just
straight-up animal abuse I don't know
any in a some more people do you not
that I'll admit publicly like in person
yeah no oh yeah like you know her name
the gamer girl she does say some more
videos to Kira chick she's Paula Gina
Gina Gina hokey-cokey does a some more
yeah I don't know yeah like dedicated s
Mars she just happens to sound like this
no she does do a some more videos I
thought she just plays games what
happens in those ASMR video I haven't
seen them you guys know pokeyman yes no
I'm [ __ ] kidding that's what everyone
says doc I need someone who you don't
tick-tock but like they weren't huge or
anything but it was it was [ __ ] weird
sometimes he would like grab like a
bunch of carrots and maybe a microphone
middle and then someone else would come
with a carrot they would welcome to get
info Mike yeah [ __ ] weird it'll sound
good not to me carrots yeah is anything
they broke anything I guess ASMR vibes
from my own raw footage like vlog
footage whenever I'm like holding the
camera it's a great bro yeah and you're
just like half the headphones I'm like
I'm just like there's a listening to the
[ __ ]
yeah good for you yeah all right
he likes the where's porn on earth you
can admit all kinds of show on this show
let's say you getting off yeah my ears
are again oh my bad my man my ears are
getting off he's getting a Meriden
response I'm judging the [ __ ]
microphone but like how hypocritical I
want you to do it if I [ __ ] hate it
oh no it's fine I really hate it the
girls important hate it too but they do
it what do you hate about it does it
make you scream like yeah it's kind of
like nails on a chalkboard for me like I
can't we'll find your M ASMR everyone
has their own yeah there's different
genre be visual I definitely have like a
visual Tamar thing we're like those are
oddly satisfying yeah
those what you just do you should do
parody ASMR of yourself where you have
the microphone here and you're like
you're like like no wait hold on me no
wait you're correcting yourself as you
do it okay should do a homeless get a
homeless man and give them a makeover
clean them up that'll be a good show how
do we jump there how do you know no okay
it's an idea that turns we're talking
YouTube does she likes to visi Vigil II
cleaned things right so like let's get a
dirty homeless man I'm waiting for you
tomorrow but never came up
that's not a sim or its visually he
would be a small homeless man then he's
cute
Brian yeah like no-neck ed on 90 day
fiancé
no neck oh my problem with it sounds too
unnatural like no one would actually do
something in that way or talk in that
way
so it makes me uncomfortable
you know I don't know like I think I'd
be okay if I had to read like a book or
something since people keep saying I
have the perfect voice for it but I
wouldn't be able to do like the then go
read a children's block I would some
money I wouldn't say the perfect words
let's say it's like a nine Steve nine
it's perfect you know great name boys
its sleepy boy again give us a sample
yeah this is a greatest boy yeah it was
gonna work nine point five he just
talked to me when I go to sleep back and
forth I do it's called nagging nagging
ASMR I like that
ding maybe that's you could get you
Kovan and you actually make money
venting nagging ASMR are giving Casey
that complaining you're orally stepping
on guy's balls yeah you can make those
million bucks at that example you can
we're talking about so young here so I'm
gonna show you guys the compilation of
her what's she doing beating up Paris is
gonna be a little rough morning - Steve
- and I think Steve figured like animals
ruff pal oh she's mean to animals in
this okay so listen hold on before I
play it listen let's remember she's from
South Korea they tend to you like live
octopus and stuff right okay but a lot
of people and I'm included in this feel
like she kind of takes it a bit too far
and it's like a little too disrespectful
little - she's being a little too
playful slaps it around a little bit it
kind of sucks because like she's like
cutting out like severing limbs without
them fully dying and then she's like
putting like salt or soy sauce on them
and they're like squirming and it's like
kind of hard to watch so warning okay
here we go is she hiding a pigeon off of
a head I've seen her like Papa been
exporting wait that's weird
no creams eaten live squid full-size
things very nice chick does live octopus
but here we go
oh my goodness oh my god that thing is
massive oh oh I mean that's how you're
supposed to do it right that's not their
head the brain is behind the eyes well
they're still alive technically okay so
they're still how do you mind if you're
technically alive just see again well
the bottom half is not anymore because
it's not connected to the brain right
doesn't matter on the live parts on the
head are in that part so the brain is
behind their eyeballs which is where the
tentacles are that seems oh my god over
top part then oh my god well the mental
oh my god
empty space that thing is awesome oh my
god
holy moly oh well I mean they come from
a salty water so they do he probably
breathe better
octopuses that [ __ ] huge thing is
huge
and then there's fish let's see wait
what is your bag of salt
why oh that's kind of torturing yeah
does she eat that big [ __ ] octopus
live
[Music]
Oh crazy her acting sucks too at least
she's freaking out and then she's not
just like what is this that's like
random as video or she's like in the
forest is that octopus you find the not
suppose in the forum no she put it there
[Laughter]
oh why like wha dude this is crazy
intense just like Dorothy by the way
yeah so yeah there's some intense video
intense backlash after like Ethan has
highlighted and then there's this other
youtuber was the backlash but in season
the right way tell her I've also made a
video about her and that's when and by
the way she used like Epsom salt for
that [ __ ] she didn't use like regular
table salt so it's even more heated Oh
wasn't it like rock salt yeah I probably
was I'm just making it use the Himalayan
pink salt on contrary I believed you Joe
you're so you're playing me so I did a
good yeah dude that the fish it was kind
of sad the octopus was this family man
what was she doing was she biting the
tent it like the the tentacle like and
just eating it alive like I didn't see
that and they're smart too aren't they
smart yeah they're smart very
intelligent so they came like solve
puzzles and get out of jars they can
yeah break open cages and they're also
really tasty like really okay so are
pigs man pigs are smartest [ __ ]
they're delicious well listen I mean
like a lot of people in this room have
tried live live octopus right but
they're killed like humanely first not
really not the way that they had it
faster though it's better than had it on
a plate News live right
got a lady that just got scissors and
started [ __ ] chopping that
[ __ ] up and then just put it on
it that's how they normally do it I
don't know there is no no I was in Korea
there is no humane way to really kill an
octopus isn't it like they're supposed
to puncture the brain first and then
kill I mean yeah but that thing is
slippery as [ __ ] how they gonna find the
brain and puncture it that that [ __ ]
going like that it's really hard for me
to judge her because I know in Korea
they do eat all kinds of live octopus
and squid and stuff I guess and I've ate
it myself but the wood I think that part
that rubs me the wrong way is how she
plays with the food a little bit extra
and I know just in both the film and
YouTube industry they're both just gonna
be wasteful industries right like when
we're doing like let's say just kidding
partying really how many Cheetos getting
stuff in her mouth we have like this
much Cheetos most of them we only use
maybe this much but you have to buy more
than you need and because this is AI
contaminator in the air you have to
throw all these Cheetos away - just like
in film industry when they have like the
craft ease or whatever after the film
day is done you can't be having cheese C
in there for 48 hours so you just take
all that craft ease you throw it away so
with that in mind that big-ass octopus
after that the playful thing I don't I
I'm assuming they didn't eat the whole
octopus they probably just brought the
big-ass octopus in for entertainment
value and then and then they let it go
yeah get it out of here let's go get
some McDonald's so like I don't know
that'sthat's what is a button mom so she
does eat the whole yeah but not the
whole lot of fish videos man in my sheet
she goes to town on as long as she let
that big octopus go then I think she's
far after eating one of it it was the
whole like we're talking about cultural
things right is that culture for her to
like salt an entire thing of fish while
they're octopus and then bite into it
you know yeah what if she's Korean in
the octopus is Japanese I think it's
been it's okay yeah that makes sense
it's just our piece for yeah which is
revenge actually
spokesperson said in a statement quote
our trust and safety team is located
around the globe and we draw upon this
regional expertise when drafting our
policies we have strict policies
regarding animal abuse and have
determined the videos highlighted
highlighted do not violate them so
that's why her videos are still up but
she her and her team they did go in and
edit a lot of her videos because you
know how YouTube now has editing tools
embedded in the platform so they were
able to remove the scenes that I just
showed you guys from the original videos
and she also pinned a comment and
practically all her videos that say this
hi everyone its Sooyoung recently I've
seen all of your comments and advice and
fully understand now I've been showing
all the process of foods getting
prepared in order to deliver the
information and pleasure for the viewers
however I realized that I was
unintentionally causing inconvenience to
others when I was preparing or cleaning
the seafood I behaved a bit Blythe or
careless manner I will be more careful
and try to work with seriousness after
accepting all of your opinions and
advice so that way I can improve my
channel and my self they clean it with
salt and that's what thankfully people
from 100 different countries are
watching my channel I will try to make
more global contents that can assimilate
cultures and races I hope you guys have
a good day thank you that's a really
nice responsive yeah
it's also informed right so I didn't
know they clean them with salt
I don't know about that I don't know how
they are I don't know anything about it
and an Asian seafood - you literally
cook alive a lot
yeah they throw things eels on on grills
and they like squirm on the heat that's
which is pretty nuts to us but like come
over there and when you go to the market
you tend to just buy it live yeah and
you want to keep the fish live when you
when it gets home so you can vs. own we
all want fresh fish I mean you have a
club but it's different because in that
we're not playing with it no I'm not
I'll never defend that I mean nobody
we're but out here though you already
get a fillet you get the fish clean your
to get the fish or like you get the
shrimp the shelled frozen so it's it's
it's not the same I guess like in Asia
or
you get it at the market and it's still
flipping around you do get fresh crab
here though I know my when my mom would
get fresh crab or even Asian markets
half the seafood we should try to like
before she threw in the boiling water
she would like stab it through its brain
first with a knife and into it it would
last you're right yeah I actually
recently bought Lobster and I found out
that the most humane way to kill the
lobster first before cooking it is to
put in the refrigerator and let the cold
put them asleep put it to sleep and
they'll die in the cold yeah yeah it's
more painless
I learned that afterwards I learned it
after I chased him around my kitchen
while he was fighting for his life with
a butcher knife legs also he stopped
moving and then I stabbed him but then I
was like oh should I miss his head and
then I stabbed it again I was like oh
that's his abdomen and that's dead in
the head yes then I just gave up on it
he was still alive and there yeah that's
crazy now cuz I couldn't all my stuff
live before growing up that's how um my
parents did that's what my dad does do
like there's the freshest yeah but see
that's this word and maybe Ethan had a
blind spot maybe I think that that was
[ __ ] up but I think that what your
guys are talking about is not
illegitimate like it is a she just what
people do and like put it on steroids
and she's like she's like stroking like
tentacles like it's tentacle porn you
know and finding an optimist in the
woods what the [ __ ] was crazy
it's like [ __ ] for example there and
this is sounds so unrelated but I
promise you it's worth it it's related
in Wade with how we all can react to
something so there's a guy named Max
Kellerman he's a he's an ESPN guy the
boxing boxing guy he also comments
sometimes on football cuz of other
things so he just commented about how
the GM of the Giants was sitting in a
room with them with the mascot and he
had a corona master on it's just him in
a room because they all drafted from
their homes and he was joking about how
he's sitting there alone with the mascot
you don't have to do that and everyone
probably at home was also doing that
joke too and like [ __ ] around or but
he the Giants guy I used to have cancer
so he has a pre-existing condition
and then there are camera guy
in the room and there are a couple
people from the organization there so
he's just trying to defend his life from
fire yeah but the guys on ESPN clowning
on the guy sitting there with the mat
idiots doing a bit right now he doesn't
know the guy's [ __ ] medical history
and you could argue well he should he's
one of those paid TV people he should
know all that [ __ ] but he's just [ __ ]
around it live I'm sure they're on there
for four hours because they'll draft us
so long and yeah he's good rekt right
now yeah but he didn't know about that
and so I think maybe some people I I
didn't know about the live octopus
eating on a plate thing until I met you
guys and I probably where said it was
[ __ ] up every single time 10 times out
of 10 even the one that you experienced
where the lady cuts it up and puts it on
your plate cuz I don't know about that
[ __ ] that's not how I was raised with
live animals in the house and you eat
them later or whatever right I remember
my dad bringing home a lobster one time
and it was pretty [ __ ] up and I was
like yeah I don't think I would do this
and I don't think he would do it again
either because it was like crazy but you
guys are used to that and so I
understand more of it because I
understand more of that perspective and
I don't think a lot of people do true
and I also like for me to it's I don't
know if this is weird to think about but
like for me it's like I also consider
how other animals consume animals and
[ __ ] off and yeah in nature and what
in nature lions will kill the prey and
they'll eat the meat off the dead of a
dead like carcass right and in nature
they do play with their prey too and
they do play don't grab a throw a
[ __ ] lamb in the air and have
it slam on the floor they're like swing
it around and then with seafood though
most of times I don't think they killed
that their prey and then eat it they
just eat the prey like whales just go on
a whole bunch of fish and they just take
or a shark will [ __ ] up your whole side
and then come at you again and for
another angle sea lions kind of nature
you know what sea lions are cute it's
like okay should we just follow it
because its nature right it's because
it's removed from us at this point like
right always also just do everything
that nature does right if ethics is
confusing because sometimes you're like
should I just say it's okay because it's
a different culture but sometimes you
look at that culture and it's so [ __ ]
up like ignoring the animal things right
you can even push
towards like Human Rights things right
right okay how they treat women in
certain countries that it's okay just
because in that culture or that country
it's okay yeah like some cultures rape
is okay yes right I mean it's a
difficult question that even like
scholars still study today in traffic
girl what's right and wrong the Viking
if you if you were a lady slave or
something of the village and then the
the leader of the village died it was
your duty to die with the leader oh [ __ ]
yeah Jesus and then before you dive you
[ __ ] everybody and then you died
[Music]